et grâce à la mobilisation à une forte
mobilisation
mais le 22 mars vous avez vu ou que la
confédération cfdt a appelé à une
manifestation où va la cgt appelle oui
mais vous a pas échappé mais comme
maintenant
oui le décret si vous a pas échappé
depuis un an classé le dt devenue la
première organisation syndicale et vous
a pas échappé depuis quelques années que
la cfdt ne se demande pas ce que font
telle ou telle organisation pour savoir
ce qu'elle a à faire
elle même le 22 mars moi j'ai vu il y à
des appels
vous n'avez pas manifesté il y à des
appels successifs sur tout un tas de
sujets et au final y en a même un
aujourd'hui sur la réforme de la
formation professionnelle
en gros ça devient une manifestation
anto fourre tout moi je préfère des
manifestations ciblées par exemple le 15
mars on va manifester sur la situation
dans les ehpad situation dramatique
on va en parler plus tard dramatique
pour les usagers dramatique pour les str
les professionnels je préfère aller sur
des objectifs ciblés pour faire aboutir
des évolutions concrètes pour les
travailleurs et 22 mars vers et au delà
le 22 mars on verra si par exemple la
sncf sur un conflit cibler les semis
n'ont pas la grève mais à la mobile à la
manifestation
pour l'instant ils ont dit qu'ils se
revoyaient le 15 mars